سالنا الناس في العراق ومصر هل تعتقد ان
الرجال يصابون ايضا باعراض سن الياس
[موسيقى]
رون بعده مراحل يعني مرحله المراهقه عند
النساء هي مرحله واحده بدايه العمر لكن
الرجال يعني اغلبهم يمر بمرحله مراهقه
يعني
متاخرالصراحه الرجال يعني ما يمرون بسنه
الياس بسبب انه روحهم الخضراء وكل ما
الكبرى بالسن يعني تحسهم شباب راح عندهم
المراهقه ثلاث مراحل مرحله ال- 20 ومرحله
الاربعينه والستينات
ويحب الحياه اكثر
ويحب النساء لان النساء احنا يعني نقول سر
الحياه
بالحقيقه الرجال ما يوصلون الى سن الياس
بشوف كل ما يكبر كل ما تكون روحه خضراء
وتكون علاقات نازجه
[موسيقى]
في راجل ممكن ال ال ممكن الحاله النفسيه
تاثر عليه الشخصيه لكن في ناس لا يعني انا
الحمد لله انا وصلت ل 55 سنه و56 سنه بس
انا مبسوط ومرتاح وبابقى سعيد جدا وبسعد
نفسي بنفسي
ممكن مثلا يبقى عنده طموح اكثر في شغله
والسفر بره طبعا
في الظروف
ومع السن مع التفكير
[موسيقى]